la mia storia inizia 18 anni fa
conosco un uomo gentile riservato
ora che ci ripenso esageratamente
educato io ho 26 anni lavoro sono
circondata di amici certe realtà che
avevo sentito distrattamente alla tv non
mi appartenevano questa persona
inizialmente gentile a tratti comincia a
dare segni di instabilità cambia
facilmente umore diventa nervoso per
situazioni ridicoli e dai primi insulti
passa velocemente a usare le mani
scopro che aspettiamo una splendida
bambina ma questo crea e lui ancora più
instabilità le botte diventano
settimanali quasi quotidiane e sempre
più brutali ed iniziano per me quelli
che saranno dodici anni di violenza di
solitudine di controllo di oppressione
che mi trasformeranno giorno dopo giorno
in una persona senza più voglia di
ridere di parlare credo di vivere
intorno mi era stato appositamente
creato il vuoto assoluto della mia
storia mi resta un naso rotto un timpano
rotto e ricordi di pugni calci morsi
mani che stringono la gola fino a far
perdere i sensi
ma oggi sono fiera di essere qui a dire
che più di tutto mi rimane la mia vita e
la mia libertà il momento di dire basta
è arrivato dopo gli ultimi due anni in
cui la situazione era diventata davvero
allucinante
ero certa che qualunque cosa avessi
fatto mi avrebbe uccisa e portato via
mia figlia la ferocia con la quale mi
picchiava con pugni calci era
allucinante
quando prendendomi dai capelli con una
mano e afferrando un coltellaccio da
cucina nell'altra mi minacciava che mi
avrebbe ammazzato se non mi facevo
tagliare i capelli da lui e ricordo me
riflessa nello specchio ferma immobile
senza respiro mentre lui con le forbici
dava dei tagli netti e nei capelli
la notte cui dopo calci nell'inguine
pugni e schiaffi
mi afferrava per il collo e cominciava a
sentire
le sue grida sempre più lontane e in
quel momento l'unica cosa che riuscivo a
pensare era che stavo morendo e dopo non
so quanto mi ritrovavo con i suoi occhi
davanti alla faccia che mi diceva a
[ __ ] non sei morta no non lo ero
vorrei che questo racconto potesse
arrivare alle donne che vivono questo
incubo perché gli abusi che si subiscono
possono essere superati perché se giorno
dopo giorno riescono ad affrontare la
violenza e rialzarsi possono essere
altrettanto forti da dire basta tutto
questo
in quei momenti ci si sente sole è
assolutamente vero ma tutta questa
solitudine termina nel momento stesso in
cui se ne esce fuori
ho dovuto affrontare il giudizio della
gente di psicologi di giudici ma con una
fondamentale differenza tra quel giorno
chi decideva della mia vita ero solo io
il primo passo è quello di rivolgersi ai
centri antiviolenza e legali del settore
perché in quei momenti si ha bisogno di
chi conosce a fondo queste situazioni in
modo da non farci sentire sbagliate
perché di sbagliato c'è solo chi
maltratta il dopo è fatto di momenti di
sconforto di momenti in cui bisogna
ricostruirsi e rimpossessarsi della
propria autostima ma credo che una volta
fatta la scelta tutto questo possa
servire a far capire quanto sia grande
ciò che si li ha ripresi volevano
reprimermi ed invece continua ancora a
credere nelle cose belle della vita e
che gli uomini non sono tutti cosi e il
compagno che ha avuto la fortuna di
incontrare me ne dà conferma giorno dopo
giorno
oggi più che mai io e mia figlia
abbiamo il pieno possesso delle nostre
vite
lei con i suoi 17 anni quasi 18 io con i
miei 44 quasi 45
ecco io questa sera sono qui da un per
parlarvi di violenza ma per parlarvi di
libertà voglio parlarvi di libertà
partendo da quello che ha detto questa
donna perché questo che vi ho letto non
sono le mie parole ma sono le parole di
questa donna e del suo percorso di
uscita dalla violenza
cosa avete pensato quando lei mi ha
raccontato di aver trovato questo uomo
così gentile troppo gentile o cosa avete
pensato quando vi ha raccontato di tutte
le violenze che ha subito e alla fine
luglio ha detto a non sei morta e lei
dentro di sé ha detto no non sono morta
e cosa avete pensato invece quando lei
ha parlato della sua libertà forse vi
siete sentiti rassicurati quando ha
detto che aveva trovato un uomo
meraviglioso è diverso da lui io sono
qui a parlarvi solo di libertà sono qui
a parlarvi di libertà di scegliere di
libertà di decidere di libertà per tutti
noi di fare le scelte che ci
appartengono ma per parlare di libertà
quando si parla di violenza bisogna
cominciare uscendo dagli stereotipi
uscendo dal pensiero comune che abbiamo
tutti noi quando pensiamo a una donna
che subisce violenza e la pensiamo come
una vittima fatta esattamente come noi
vogliamo ci immaginiamo che sia
e allora come ci immaginiamo una donna
che subisce violenza domestica ce la
immaginiamo come una donna che si è
dimessa sia una casalinga
forse non ha un lavoro e allora doveva
se non ha un lavoro non ha
un'indipendenza economica invece le
donne che hanno un lavoro perché restano
forse perché si sentono isolate perché
lui ha creato loro il vuoto intorno
magari avevano un lavoro ma poi lo hanno
lasciato perché lui glielo ha chiesto
quando hanno avuto il primo figlio o
loro stesse hanno pensato che fosse
giusto così
perché questa società tutti ci
aspettiamo che una buona mamma si occupi
prima dei suoi bambini che della sua
realizzazione personale o come noi ci
possiamo immaginare invece una donna che
subisce violenza sessuale noi ce la
immaginiamo come lo sterotipo che
abbiamo della donna che subisce questo
reato e cioè come una ragazza che va in
discoteca con la minigonna e che beve e
trova qualcuno che la stupra o come un
incosciente che va a fare jogging nel
parco durante la notte è certamente
trovali il suo stupratore
ecco quello che vedo io non è questo
io vedo ragazze come voi che escono con
un loro coetaneo di buona famiglia e di
buona educazione che non accetta o no
perché nessuno gli ha insegnato ad
accettare un no io vedo donne che vanno
a lavorare e che il loro stupratore lo
trovano al lavoro in qualcuno che le
molesta o che lo trovano nel parcheggio
quando escono tardi perché hanno fatto
gli straordinari per essere considerate
sul luogo di lavoro oppure e questo non
ve lo dirà mai nessuno ma io sono qui
per dirmelo
il loro stupratore lo trovano a casa
quando tornano a casa e non perché lui
si è introdotto nelle loro case ma
semplicemente perché loro marito
compagno amorevole che anche lui non ha
imparato ad accettare un no perché anche
a lui
nessuno lo ha insegnato e allora di che
cosa dobbiamo parlare dobbiamo parlare
delle buone relazioni della capacità di
stare in parità nelle buone relazioni
perché la violenza si annida proprio lì
nell'incapacità di avere una relazione
equilibrata perché la violenza e
prevaricazione e imposizione del tuo
volere sull'altro noi quindi cosa
possiamo fare
o forse voluto essere volutamente
provocatoria ma in realtà vi ho detto
solo la verità ma noi cosa possiamo fare
beh
possiamo cominciare a pensare che lei
non è proprietà di nessuno che lei è
libera di scegliere che lei non ha fatto
niente per meritarselo
e smetterla di andare a cercare sul
giornale o in televisione cambiando
canale i particolari morbosi della sua
vita chiedendoci se lei è stata
violentata perché tutto sommato si era
vestita in quel modo
ed era andata in quel posto e aveva
bevuto ed aveva un'amante e ricordarci
che lei non ha fatto niente per
meritarselo
ecco forse dobbiamo cambiare la nostra
visione della violenza e della vittima
di violenza che ci aspettiamo
dobbiamo pensare che la violenza non è
un'emergenza non è qualcosa che capita
all'improvviso è che noi non ci
aspettiamo e non sappiamo cos'è e non
sappiamo da dove arriva qualche volta lo
è ma molto raramente
in realtà nella maggioranza dei casi la
violenza è qualcosa che ti aspetta a
casa nel luogo più sicuro dove tu ti
sentiresti sicura e va avanti per anni
anni anni nella totale indifferenza di
tutti noi
allora giustamente ci chiediamo
continuiamo a chiederci cosa possiamo
fare è molto facile esserle accanto
aiutarla ad uscire dall'isolamento
perché lui questo fa la isola per poter
continuare indisturbato ad agire
violenza noi possiamo fare qualcosa per
evitare che lei resti nella violenza
perché chi agisce violenza limita anche
la nostra libertà e noi questo lo
dobbiamo dire con forza e lo dobbiamo
pensare ogni giorno perché una donna che
subisce violenza non ha bisogno di
essere salvata perché un essere pensante
non è una donna incapace che non riesce
a decidersi è solo una donna che
gestisce che aspetta il momento che
cerca di restare viva mentre aspetta al
momento perchè quando qualcuno vi
stringe le mani alla gola e cerca di
soffocarmi
forse pensate a respirare e non pensate
se non avete i soldi per comprare il
latte perché lui non ve li ha dati il
vostro unico pensiero restar vive e che
i vostri figli restino vivi la donna del
racconto nel suo processo ci ha detto
che una volta la sua bambina
le ha detto mamma portami via lei andata
la porta a tenendo per mano la sua
bambina
e lui le ha detto se esci di lì sei
morta lei è tornata indietro ancora una
volta troppa era la paura troppo era il
timore che accadesse qualcosa perché una
donna che subisce violenza è abituata a
gestire la paura è abituata a fare
quello che lui desidera sperando di non
provocarlo accettare di vestirsi come
vuole lui di andare dove vuole lui di
rispondere al telefono 100 200 volte al
giorno per dire dove con chi è cosa sta
facendo accettare di dare il sesso in
cambio di tranquillità tutto per evitare
che accada il peggio
ecco questo cerca di fare una donna che
subisce violenza cerca di gestire il
momento per evitare che tutto degeneri
perché lei sa che se lo lascia potrebbe
essere peggio perché lei sa e ce lo
dicono anche le statistiche che se lo
lascia quello il momento più rischioso
perché lui potrebbe decidere di
ucciderla potrebbe cercare di portare
via i suoi figli perché lui e lo dice la
minaccia continuamente se mi lasci ti
porto via i bambini e anche se questo
poi non accade
lei dovrà affrontare serranti battaglie
giudiziarie in cui lui chiederà di stare
con i bambini la metà del tempo anche se
non li ha mai accuditi in cui lui la
dipingerà come una pessima madre e direi
bambini quando occasione di stare con
loro è tutta colpa di mamma e lei che ha
voluto andarsene in fondo eravamo una
famiglia così felice
e allora noi dobbiamo pensare a cosa
possiamo fare non vedendo la donna
sempre come una vittima
noi dobbiamo pensare
perla come la vittima che vorremmo
perché noi siamo abituati a pensare che
le donne che subiscono violenza siano
delle donne remissive che non sappiano
cosa stanno facendo
in realtà la verità è un'altra accettano
lo sputo l'insulto per evitare l'ha
percossa accettano la denigrazione per
evitare di essere aggredite
quindi noi dobbiamo smetterla di pensare
le cose che noi ci aspettiamo che
accadano e di pensare le cose per come
sono e quindi non giudichiamo una donna
che aspetta al momento non giudichiamo
una donna che è stata violentata solo
per come era vestita
proviamo a cambiare la nostra
prospettiva proviamoci ma proviamoci
veramente quindi non interessiamoci di
come vestita se lo ha provocato
cos'ha fatto se aveva bevuto dove era
andata interessiamoci di quello che lei
ha subito della violazione della sua
libertà
sono di questo noi ci dobbiamo
interessare e non di altro noi dobbiamo
pensare alla sua libertà al fatto che
lei deve essere sempre e comunque libera
di scegliere che lei deve essere sempre
comunque libera di decidere
pensiamoci pensiamoci molto la sua
libertà pensiamoci
e allora pensiamoci fin da subito
pensiamoci quando iniziamo il percorso
della nostra vita
pensiamo che questa donna deve avere
diritto a fare in studi che desidera a
trovare un lavoro proporzionato agli
studi che ha fatto e paritariamente
retribuito deve avere diritto a fare la
stessa carriera dei suoi colleghi
anche se decide di avere un bambino devi
avere diritto ad avere un asilo nido a
un prezzo accessibile quando decide di
tornare al lavoro
ecco noi questo dobbiamo pensare che una
donna che resta nella violenza non è una
donna che ha bisogno di essere protetta
non è una donna che ha bisogno di essere
gestita non è una donna che ha bisogno
di essere salvata e una donna che deve
essere sempre e comunque libera
decidere noi questo dobbiamo pensare
dobbiamo vedere la donna che si trova
nella violenza esattamente così come un
essere umano molto coraggioso che
gestisce la sua paura per salvare se
stessa e suoi figli perché vedete le
donne spesso non parlano perché hanno
paura di non essere credute le donne
spesso non escono dalla violenza perché
non conoscono i loro diritti e noi molto
possiamo fare per fare in modo che loro
conoscono i loro diritti e aiutarle a
rivolgersi dove trovano le giuste
informazioni
perché forse dobbiamo cominciare
veramente a cambiare prospettiva e
allora mi rivolgo a te se ti offende se
tu miglia se ti denigra se ti minaccia
se ti aggredisce se ti percuote e allora
mi rivolgo a te se limita la tua libertà
se ti controlla al telefono se ti
impedisce di lavorare se controlla i
tuoi spostamenti e il tuo cellulare
non la cagliano fare rivolgersi a un
centro antiviolenza informati sui tuoi
diritti perché uscire dalla violenza si
può perché se è libera di scegliere
perché sei libera di decidere e noi per
favore non chiamiamo la vittima e noi
per favore non chiamiamo la vittima e
noi per favore non chiamiamo la vittima
[Applauso]